at the bataclan concert hall in paris
some people managed to escape through a
side door inside gunman was shooting at
the crowd
earlier the attackers had rampaged
across the city killing people in
several locations by the end of the
evening 130 people were dead in an
attack claimed by isil
the french president declared a state of
emergency across france there was shock
and grief
nearly six years on thomas smith
remembers how an evening of enjoying
live music at the bataclan rapidly
turned into a nightmare
all of a sudden people fell to the floor
i turned around and saw two people army
kalashnikovs shooting everything that
moved i called on the floor everyone was
trying to crawl it was a mess the lights
went out we heard more shouting someone
shouted they're reloading he had three
seconds and then i just ran
most of the attackers blew themselves up
or were shot dead by police on the night
three days later police killed a man
suspected to be the mastermind of the
attacks in a paris suburb but it was
four months before the man alleged to be
the only surviving attacker was arrested
salah abdeslam had been in hiding in
belgium salah abdeslam is one of 20
accused in the paris attacks trial six
will be tried in absentia proceedings
will take place here in paris high court
in a specially built courtroom hundreds
of witnesses are expected to testify
among them survivors this lawyer says
that for the victims it's been a long
wait for justice
to be honest and under my own experience
for victims
they cannot put all these behind it is
very difficult but it can helps them to
go ahead and to know that okay even
after six long years there is a trial
and this trial is important thomas says
he's anxious about the trial but hopes
that his testimony will help others
the only thing it can do perhaps is to
help others say like i do i can be okay
and that motivates me to testify
the trial is scheduled to last nine
months it may shed more light on what
happened that night how the attacks were
planned and whether they could have been
prevented years on paris's cafes and
bars are busy but reminders and memories
of that night are never very far away
natasha butler al jazeera paris